the fear of psychosis
well
i i certainly think it has been used to
warn people away i mean that's what was
we were told is you'll lose your mind
and i remember when i was first
when i was a proselytizing 19 year old
having taken my first lsd trip and then
i went home for christmas
convinced that i would turn my parents
and i just realized uh
these people don't want to do this
because they know they're crazy
that is the bottom line they actually
know it they're comfortable with it
they they don't want to mess with their
minds
because they sense the fragileness of it
all
i think it was tim leary who said
lsd is a drug which occasionally causes
psychotic reactions in people who
haven't taken it
that was certainly
that was certainly the case in my family
i mean all you had to do was mention
that
people would hit the ceiling and begin
twitching and
their eyes would roll back and
say my goodness this is a powerful
concept
this this question of how how dangerous
are psychedelics i think anybody
anybody who deals with them eventually
comes up against this well the question
you have to ask is to whom
or to what
what is it that they threaten
i don't
feel um
afraid of dying
i really think that if you die on a
psychedelic it probably is
a decision or the revelation of a
cardiac dysrhythmia or something like
that and it could have happened to you
jogging or swimming or in the baths that
you know some of us are delicately
poised and we don't realize it until
it's too late
the the psychosis thing there are two
schools
i think at least two schools and one
school is this is what is supposed to
happen you're supposed to take this
and break down completely and yell and
howl and flop on the floor and beg for
mercy and have to be straight jacketed
and so forth and then after nine or ten
hours
uh you're all right
and you say
wow that really did me a lot of good i
really got that was great
well i'm not of that school
and it may be and i fully i'm willing to
fully entertain the possibility that i
have a problem
that this let it all hang out school is
the way to go
my notion is
that i will i want to understand it and
i want to sit quietly and i don't want
to react against it and i don't want to
push into it and i just say you know
please
be nice
and show
that's what i say to it i say show
thing
show
show what you know
and then it begins to pull back the
veils
and reveal and it's a dialogue
and i i don't
i
i really don't like losing control
and i've come to see that as an issue
for me
i never have lost control except in
situations where it was such a total
loss of control that that was not an
issue in other words there was no
fighting
it just happened
yes
and you know you can lose control
i've had experiences where
something was going on i came to
awareness and something was going on and
after a long long time i realized
i'm a person
i'm on a drug
that's it i'm a person on a drug
now it's coming back to me that's it
that's it i'm in the middle of a trip
jesus
and i didn't even you know wow well this
means you know i'm all you're already on
your way down at that point
but that's not a control
issue a control issue is when you don't
want it and it still keeps coming and
you know
it humor is sometimes the only recourse
i mean you just
have to
uh
say you know kill me already
it's impossible it's just impossible
uh
i don't know you think different things
about this i think
this is an area that we talk about a
fair bit
um
somewhat yes i
terence and i generally for some
few years now uh
trip alone i mean not even together as a
couple although
there have been many times but but this
individual quiet what terence does the
the searching uh asking
is so
rewarding
to me
that i i find myself going away your
question about how to prepare for it
i'll just tell you how i prepare i meet
it with fear and with courage every time
you know but the fear is always there
and five grams is a serious step you
know sometimes you're surprised in five
grams was much less than you thought
other times it's
you know beyond the beyond
i go away
to a cabin by myself for a few days and
uh
try to keep my sense of humor before
during and after
be clean in
terms of diet but
attitudes and shed whatever it is that
i'm carrying around in my daily
hassling or whatever
and
ask
know that i'm not really alone in it
because i think that that fear of really
being totally alone in it is is one of
the things that overwhelms people i um
don't call it thing as terence claims
that he does but i do find that that uh
there's an it is an entity there are
entities in it whether it is one or it's
just filled with many but you can ask
for the security of having one be the
communicator with you
so in some cases um
well i always invoke something at the
beginning beforehand
someone that i can relate to uh
in some cases it has been the great
goddess of the ancients because she can
take so many different forms i leave
that up to her but i can ask for a voice
or a face or a shower you know to be
there so so it has more form to it
because the the total formlessness you
meet sometimes in the middle of a trip
it can be truly terrifying and confusing
and not instructional
and then other times it's been an
ancestor a known ancestor or a or
whatever makes sense to you someone told
me she always asks her grandmother to be
there and
just
do the channeling you know and whatever
form you put to it has a has a power
uh sets up a field then that the
information will have to contend with
and and uh
i over the last four or five years i've
just become
very secure with that
approach so that i trust
the dose and i trust the situation then
what comes through during that
experience is still
always the unexpected
but it's that's fine that's then what
you learn you know
and then there
many of us here i think have talked
about techniques but some of you are new
to our discussions so maybe not a basic
thing to say is the breathing is always
very very important and
anyone going into a trip of on anything
should know that conscious awareness of
your breath and however you choose to do
that
will have the greatest modulating effect
on the content of anything you can do
sometimes it's just a simple
following you're inhaling and exhaling
sometimes it becomes stronger or a
blowing
and then there's singing which we were
talking about last night it's
the you know the oxygen is a in itself
the sound is a dimension unto itself
it doesn't have to be a song with words
or you don't have to be good at it it's
just singing in that context just means
letting your
body
manifest the vibration that you are
perceiving you're perceiving so many at
once and your body wants to resonate
with it and so it will if you just let
it make sound and that
something about the sound and the oxygen
combined is is so uh
makes you at one with everything
so these are these are techniques for
dealing with the dread and the dread is
terrifying you know and although many of
us we wouldn't be so talk so interested
in this talking about it if we hadn't
had beautiful
dazzling and hilarious trips as well
fortunately more of them seem to be that
but
if you're on a quest you're going to
meet dragons you're going to meet
everything you know and and then it's
good to know what to do when you meet
those
i think that that's something that
anybody who's concerned about
preparation should be most concerned
about is
mindset
mm-hmm
well it's almost as though the trip
gives off a vibration backward through
time before it happens
so for instance the evening
uh you know an hour before you're about
to drop
you often feel as though you've already
taken it
and if that feeling is unpleasant
you can violate the inevitability of the
kazoo history and not taking
you know i mean well many things are
going on when you trip i think which is
that you're you're checking into your
deepest self
but you're also
taking a weather report on the cosmos
for that moment you know and so you may
be fine at that moment but it is good as
terence says to check out what is the
feeling of everything what information
came in subliminally to me today whether
it was on the news or something somebody
told me which set up a field that i've
acted like wasn't important and yet you
can
we've learned to tell the kinds of
things which might overwhelm you once
you get into that state
do i want to be overwhelmed by that okay
or not okay you know
a lot of what you will encounter are are
the moods of
the world of
the atmosphere in the moment you take it
and that's part of the uh
can't always get what you want factor
and the more the more conscious you are
before the experience
the easier it will be
there's an old catholic trick that comes
into play here
the way i usually do it is i
i
take it
and then it won't come on for like an
hour an hour and 20 minutes but i sit in
the dark that hour some people say well
it's not going to come on for an hour so
let's i've got this videotape i'd like
you to see and
no i just as soon as i take it i treat
the situation as though i've entered the
sacral space and in the
hour before it comes on i usually manage
to carry out a fairly detailed
examination of conscience
this is the catholic trick
you just i i anticipate everything in my
personality
and world situation that might cause me
to have a bad trip
say you know well you're cutting corners
on this and you really haven't squarely
faced that
and so forth and so on well by the time
the thing actually comes on you've
usually processed most of this and then
you can just say okay
now let her rip
but if you hadn't done that in the
preceding hour why it might be waiting
for you there and
i think most psychedelic researchers
agree
five out of ten new york psychedelic
researchers agree
that
[Applause]
[Music]
that
the
ordinary way
that the a person's psychedelic use
develops is the first trips are the most
unpredictable
and the most self-involved
and that's when you know you remember
when you were molested or this or that
it's all about you and your hang-ups and
understanding your place in the world
and what's going on but if you press
through that
and continue
experimenting with these things nobody
is so screwed up that that part of it
can go on forever eventually you begin
to break out into a kind of generalized
dimension where you say this isn't about
me this has nothing to do with me this
is the place the ancient books were
talking about this is what religion and
shamanism and myth is about in other
words past the
disentangling of the shock of a personal
and unexamined personal unconscious is
the more mystical and transcendental
realms and a lot of people don't persist
to reach that
they find the
rubbing their nose in all of their own
personal stuff so odious
that they just call a halt right there
and can't understand why anybody would
take these things
i mean people say you know you do this
for fun
no not exactly it's just the best form
of entertainment that we know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you